si vous êtes amateur de hard rock sans
doute vous connaissez motörhead ce
groupe anglais fête ses 30 ans
d'existence le chanteur et ses deux
musiciens se vante de jouer plus fort
que n'importe quel autre groupe au monde
et vous allez le voir leurs fans sur des
inconditionnels jusqu au look bureau no
le dreff dominique marault tel et régis
matter çà fait parfois c'était fait là
et ça fait toujours ce sont là ces mots
tu auras
oui
pour ses 30 ans le groupe joue à guichet
fermé avec fans en grande tenue
t-shirt obligatoire tatouage recommandé
ça veut dire quoi on va ni pour perdre
vivre pour gagner wierre incontournable
sylvain et fabrice ont fait le voyage
jusqu'à londres il fait partie de la
confrérie motörhead et ça se voit
obligés d'aller les manger ya six mois
j'étais en allemagne aujourd'hui je suis
ici parce que la france est vue d'un
petit peu quoique c'est dommage s'il
vous plaît chez aurel est devenu une
référence moi c'est d'une autoroute
la vie à deux genres de musique c'était
mais s'est levé d'un pad tu vois c'est
simple pour certains nous sommes le pire
coupe du monde pour l'autre est
meilleure pour aimer motörhead
il n'y a ni âge ni 7 ça fait un moment
qu'ils ont du jeu tablier spécialement
pour eux non je suis toujours comme ça
mais bon c'est bien pour les concerts
qu'elle a 15 ans quand on aime on ne
compte pas
t-shirt souhaite casquette et même
string tout va ce vraiment manchon ses
25 livres 69
combien pensez vous en vendre ma des
milliers vous n'avez plus une livre il
reste tout de même le concert et ça s'en
lasse
c'est une chanson on les adore il
reprend là j'allais oublier motörhead
c'est à écouter très fort maison il est
ce par quoi ses oreilles
voilà